to visit Ohio
I've spoken with every official in Ohio
Democrat and Republican on a continuous
basis as in Pennsylvania
and we will be implementing an awful lot
into the legislation here and I will be
under here
President Biden says he will finally
visit East Palestine a full month after
the toxic train disaster he didn't set a
time or date and interestingly blew off
the idea just a week ago but better late
than never I guess in the time Joe's
waited more than 700 tons of
contaminated soil and nearly 2 million
gallons of liquid have been collected
from the site and health concerns have
gotten worse workers cleaning up the
site are reportedly getting sick and
independent researchers think toxic
chemicals detected could pose long-term
health risks if they continue at current
levels
that finding flies in the face of
officials who've been telling residents
everything is safe
if those homes have been tested by the
state and given a clean bill of health
yes as a father I trust the science I
absolutely yes the air is safe based on
the data and we really need for the
local community to trust their state and
local government if they've had the test
the water that has been tested and the
air that has been tested is coming back
with no adverse health impact levels
Jesse how are these people supposed to
trust anything that they're they're told
about their situation when they were
told everything was fine and now the
people cleaning up the side are getting
sick they're seeing it firsthand they're
feeling it and then they're told just
trust the data that it's okay
yeah you can't trust these people after
they've lied to you for so many years
and it would go a long way if the
president would go there and put his
arms around people and drink some water
and say we'll throw as much money at you
guys for as long as you live so you
don't get sick long term when someone
says Katie I'll get to it at some point
that means never that's like when you
say when's Greg gonna grow up at some
point Greg's gonna grow up he's never
gonna grow up he's never going to East
Palestine he might as well just admit
he's never going
he If I Was President this is what I
would do Katie I would visit every place
if there was a flood here I'd go to the
flood if there was a shooting there I'd
go to the shooting a black white rich
poor I go to Indian reservations I'd go
to the Border I'd even go to Canada no I
would be on the road constantly kissing
babies hugging people
fake crying and giving speeches about
how I was going to stand with the people
for whatever situation called for this
guy doesn't do it and that's all we're
asking him to do and the only reason
he's saying at some point now is because
he's been asked about it what a dozen
times by reporters yeah well the
residents there aren't buying it and
they're still pretty outraged take a
listen
how long is going to take from watching
my family slow diving they're dying
slowly down in front of my eyes my skin
fell off my hands from grabbing the
machines when I went back to work I
couldn't breathe and I quit my jaw do I
have to wait until I have cancer or my
kids are sick or my grandkids are sick
before you guys are gonna do anything
that's not right
[Music]
now I'm begging you
you know Kaylee today the White House
Press Secretary was saying they don't
have a plan for Biden to go there I
would say it's too late for him to go I
mean it would just amplify the fact that
he's leading from behind and not even
going after people to judge what I
couldn't agree more with you it's way
too late they set up Pete butterjudge as
the Fall Guy on this that's what this
was intended to do in Buddha judge world
who knew that existed there's a Buddha
judge world according to Politico
they're very upset about it just chaston
Justin Chase it I think it is Buddha
judge has taken a lot of bullets for the
president on this is what the anonymous
Buddha judge World person said uh it's
too late to go and this is the president
who's supposed to be so empathetic how
many times have we heard that but this
is the same guy who laughed at a mom
whose two sons died of fentanyl the same
guy looked at his watch as Marines came
home from Afghanistan the same guy who
when asked about Afghans falling from
the plane said four or five days ago and
the same guy who talked about Zoom when
asked about East Palestine so we
wouldn't expect much more from him yeah
Jessica I mean this is why people don't
have trust in their local or federal
officials because they've been told that
things are safe and they've been told
that the president is empathetic and he
cares about the issue of cancer for
example and he's just been MIA
so we put together a montage of
Republican and Democrat officials all
saying it's fine
Mike dewine Johnson the government well
no but I'm saying it's important to this
because it has turned into just that Joe
Biden is a fake empath which I would
fiercely disagree with and I don't know
how people can trust their government I
think that more should show up for each
and every one of these town halls and if
you're concerned about the money which
the government always is what is the
cost of relocation until all of these
tests are consistently clear versus what
the cost could be long term for this
right if you do end up with a situation
where there are long-term cancers
um
God knows what happens when you have
toxic chemicals in your water like that
it's into the Ohio river and that's
something that a shocked that we're not
talking more about it it does seem and
President Biden gave an interview
um over the weekend I believe about what
the response actually looked like in
fact the EPA was on the ground two hours
after this happened it is not something
that has been neglected by the
administration whatsoever people to
judge going is frankly more than Elaine
Chow did when she was Transportation
secretary she never visited one single
derailment including it would have been
there there were Flint Michigan the
president would have been there people
in Flint Michigan got ignored for a very
relationship absolutely it shouldn't
have been but to say that what you're
saying is basically President Biden
would only care if it was black people
because black people vote for President
Biden but these are 5 000 poor white
people who didn't vote for President
Biden frankly a lot of poor white people
voted President Biden because he doesn't
actually care about everybody maybe not
in East Palestine that is a red State
odds are that they did not vote for him
and voted for President Trump again but
don't do that I don't agree I think this
problem's about to know let's make
agreement it sounds like it I think the
problem's gonna get a lot bigger because
the Ohio River doesn't stay in East
Palestine it flows Downstream with all
those chemicals Greg the uh you know I
don't think he's a fake empathic is that
what you said empath fake empath that's
like basically you know he's uh he just
has his priorities backwards because
while this is happening you know inside
our country you know he's pushing for
This Global Health Equity thing that
obligates Americans to hand over
something like a fifth of their medical
supplies to the World Health Association
that's it that doesn't mean that like
when we use these supplies and we're
done we hand it over to them we're not
even first in line so our health
actually becomes secondary uh to Global
Health uh and which doesn't make any
sense because obviously China has the
World Health Association in their back
pocket so it's again one of those things
where
how does how do Democrats or liberals
explain the gulf between the passion
they have for these abstract Concepts
like pronouns and inequity
and then just totally miss the boat on
this stuff like this is an America
thousands of Americans suffering but I
think politics makes them completely
blind to the suffering that's in front
of them how else is that how was that I
mean this explains DC too right so you
know it's like they're all on board with
this cushy Global BS while right here
there's God knows what's happening in
this do you think that the same goes for
let's say a Republican president who
doesn't go somewhere where there's been
a mass shooting and he doesn't show up
and say we've lost dozens of people to
gun violence in here that was actually
let's say a product of racist messaging
about the impact of brown people in the
country like the Walmart in El Paso
where he doesn't show up in Ohio after a
bar is shot up and a bunch of people
lose their lives doesn't go to
he was in Ukraine though like you should
come back and go to East Palestine well
you're getting close it wasn't hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else